Hello and welcome to MetaHuman Introduction.
My name is Gabriela Crisenio-Tacas and I will be your host for this course.
In this course we will begin with an overview of the MetaHuman framework and MetaHuman
sample projects.
From there we will go over how to access the MetaHuman creator using the Quixel Bridge
Unreal Engine 5 integration and go over some additional assets we can download with the
Quixel Bridge standalone application.
Then we will dive into the MetaHuman creator and explore all of its tools.
From there we will move into a hands-on session for creating a MetaHuman in Engine with the
MetaHuman plugin using a RealityScanFaceScan asset.
We will also go over how to bring a MetaHuman into Unreal Engine and go over some best practices
when working with them in your project.
We will wrap up this course with some final recommendations by going over how MetaHumans
can be used for vertical specific applications and I will provide you with some tips and
resources for continuing your work and training with MetaHumans.
This course will be using the project MEH9130055 and the level map should load automatically.
The map is located in the content browser under the courses folder labeled MEH11301
in the course maps folder and it is named MEH11301MAP.
This course will also use a RealityScanFaceScan asset with textures.
The asset is located under the assets folder in the folder named scanMesh.
Additionally the original OBJ file and textures have also been provided in the source files
folder named 11301 RealityScan associated with this course.
If you need to reference the location of the course map that can be found at the beginning
of the slide deck after the training outline.
Now as we go through this course you will find that many slides in this presentation
contain a lot of information and I will summarize all of that for you but if at any point you
want to read what is on each of those slides feel free to pause and dive right in.
Now let's move on to the first section of this course and begin by exploring the MetaHuman
framework and some MetaHuman sample projects.